Tradutor: Claudia Sander
Revisor: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Como pesquisadora,
estudar a cultura da mistura
e como criativa, criar projetos
a partir desse tema,
sempre foi a minha grande paixão.
Na verdade, não é nem uma grande paixão;
depois que a gente entra
numa idade de 30 anos,
e começa aquela coisa
de retorno de Saturno,
descobri que isso é muito a minha missão.
E por que que isso é uma missão?
Eu sou filha de um palestino
com uma brasileira
que é filha de uma índia com um português.
E eu fui criada dentro
duma loja popular, aquelas:
"Barato, barato. O patrão enlouqueceu.
Passa aqui", não sei quê.
Por isso eu tenho esta voz. (Risos)
Porque eu aprendi, na loja, a fazer isso.
Meu primeiro emprego.
E foi dentro dessa loja que,
assim, quem não é daqui
vai saber que é igual ao Saara,
igual à 25 de Março,
todos os lugares dos centros do país.
Foi dentro dessa loja
que, há mais ou menos 20 anos,
eu descobri que nascer neste país,
e com aquela mistura toda
que era aquela loja, aquela gente,
com o camelô que gritava,
o pacoteiro, aquela coisa toda,
que cada dia eu ficava
mais feliz com aquilo,
eu descobri que nascer aqui no Brasil
faria com que eu conseguisse ou pudesse
criar uma estratégia pra não casar mais
com um primo que eu era prometida, enfim.
Porque eu era filha de árabe,
palestino, criado aqui,
mas que tinha a cultura, mesmo no Brasil,
de ter casamentos, ou pelo menos
ter que casar com um outro árabe.
E foi a partir desse momento que eu pensei
que eu poderia ser uma mulher "livre".
Então eu disse: "Nossa, este é o país".
Eu quero, aqui que eu tenho que criar
como vou fazer pra não, enfim...
poder colocar minha voz e,
como mulher, expressar o que eu penso
e não só ser mãe, apesar de amar ser mãe,
mas mãe e mulher e esposa.
Beleza.
Daí eu adoro lembrar um pouco,
quando a gente fala de Brasil,
porque tem uma frase muito boa,
MC Carol, pra mim, hoje em dia,
tem sido a minha grande poeta.
E ela fala uma coisa, eu gosto
muito desta letra que ela fala:
"Nada contra ti, não me leve a mal,
quem descobriu o Brasil não foi Cabral".
Porque eu fico pensando
que, apesar de eu ser feliz,
ou, quando eu tinha 12 anos de idade,
descobri que nascer aqui
seria muito bom pra mim,
eu noto que as pessoas
deste lugar, deste país,
não se sentiam representadas,
não se sentiam muito felizes.
Até quando eu conversava,
antes de ser pesquisadora
já conversei com muita gente,
viajei o Brasil inteiro conversando,
fazendo campo com milhares
de jovens de todas as idades,
mas até mesmo dentro da loja,
eu via que as pessoas não se sentiam
representadas, elas diziam:
"Ah, legal, ser brasileira".
Eu dizia: "Ah, tu tem
muita sorte, tu é livre, né?"
Elas ficavam: "É... não sei..."
Então tinha essa coisa de não se sentir,
talvez, tão representada,
como até a Yasmin estava contando.
Porque, de novo, a maioria das referências
não representam o Brasil.
Gente, o Brasil é enorme,
o território brasileiro é absurdo,
me lembro quando comecei
a fazer campo, viajar,
saí do Rio Grande do Sul, eu disse:
"Meu Deus, que coisa linda".
Cada dia me apaixonava mais pelo Brasil,
quando está no Pará, quando vai
pro Nordeste, Rio de Janeiro.
E cada história!
Daria mil narrativas no Afroflix.
Então isso não é colocado, não é mostrado.
E é muito estranho, é muito triste,
a gente não ver isso né?
Por quê?
Porque tudo que a gente absorve
são referências de fora.
Eu, normalmente, como uma pessoa
que trabalha muito também com tendências,
tudo que a gente tem que olhar é pra fora.
A gente sempre olha referências nórdicas.
O que vem de cima.
O que vem não sei de onde.
Ninguém gosta de se reconhecer.
Até quando a gente viaja,
a gente quer viajar pra fora do país,
a gente não quer viajar pra dentro.
Então tem essa questão toda
de não ser representado,
mas a gente também não tem
esse grande amor de conhecer o outro
e conhecer o próprio território.
Muitas vezes eu vejo, aqui é
uma representação de um pouco de mim,
que eu não vejo nesses lugares,
mas também tem várias outras histórias,
de pessoas do Nordeste,
de pessoas do interior.
Eu poderia contar uma história aqui:
"Oh, vamos trazer a galera do interior".
Rio Grande do Sul sabe quanto,
muitas vezes, não aparece coisas gaúchas,
a gente sabe, o eixo é Rio e São Paulo.
Então, enfim, ninguém
é muito representado.
E a partir disso, na minha vida,
comecei a sentir essa missão
de não só pesquisar, mas criar projetos.
O último projeto que eu fiz
se chama "Sou Dessas".
Foi muito pra passar o microfone
pra mulheres que eu admirava;
que essas mulheres pudessem contar suas
histórias, seus movimentos, entre elas;
chamava "Sou Dessas", e principalmente
mulheres que além de ter seu trabalho,
também são articuladoras de redes;
são pessoas que misturam.
Assim como as meninas aqui,
no TEDx, também são articuladoras,
são pessoas que estão fazendo a gente
ouvir essas histórias e se misturar.
No "Sou Dessas", a gente usou o palco
pra falar de um movimento muito grande
que a gente começou
a identificar entre as mulheres,
por exemplo, que é a "sevirologia".
Quando um dos meninos estava contando
sobre a mãe, eu fiquei pensando muito:
"As mães do Brasil são
as verdadeiras 'sevirólogas'".
Porque sempre trabalham pra fazer várias
coisas e elas têm que fazer um corre,
independente de classe,
mas quando a gente vai pra periferia,
elas fazem dez vezes mais o corre,
não têm muita gente pra ajudar.
Tem, sim, os vizinhos, porque a economia
colaborativa, dentro de comunidades,
é maior até do que fora dela, mas enfim.
Então nesse dia a gente começou a discutir
e dizer: "Putz, vamos trazer mulheres,
sevirólogas e fazedoras, pra contar
suas histórias e compartilhar".
O que é sevirologia?
Muitas vezes a galera fala que é muito
como dizia o Reinaldo Pamponet,
que trouxe esse termo,
mas aqui, quando a gente ouve
sobre sevirologia,
a gente ouve muito como a gambiarra,
o jeitinho brasileiro.
Até nosso jeito de criar,
nossa criatividade,
nosso jeito difícil de se virar,
muitas vezes ele é diminuído,
não é visto como a criatividade, inovador.
Sevirologia, se fosse visto pelos caras
de tendências, seria visto como "makers".
Ou a cultura maker.
Ou iam dizer: "Nossa, os hackers", né?
E quando a gente ouve falar sobre maker,
sobre cultura hacker,
parece que está falando sobre inovadores,
que vieram de outros lugares,
dentro das suas universidades,
como outras por aí,
que são, enfim, dos Estados Unidos,
conhecidas por tecnologia e tudo mais.
Mas quando a gente traz e se reconhece:
"Eu sou um maker, eu sou uma fazedora,
eu sou um sevirólogo", começo
a entender que aquilo faz parte,
que sou uma pessoa criativa,
posso fazer acontecer.
E isso não é diminuído,
imagina, as nossas referências
são até diminuídas
e colocadas como jeitinho brasileiro,
gambiarra, em vez de dizer:
"uma grande força criativa",
"um grande jeito de trabalhar e criar
dentro de pequenas barreiras".
Este é um exemplo de sevirologia,
mas o próprio Carnaval,
o jeito que a galera cria, olha o tamanho
do Carnaval, gente, pelo amor de Deus,
é muito difícil fazer tudo aquilo.
E aquilo tudo só acontece por um trabalho
coletivo, muito bem colocado,
e por vários sevirólogos.
Então a gente identificou
diversos sevirólogos aqui,
a Yasmin foi uma das nossas convidadas
a contar a história,
mas o mais importante desses projetos
foi que a gente tem que ter o tempo todo,
na nossa cabeça, que a gente
pode ser consciência e ação.
Consciência é o saber que existem
algumas coisas e trazer essas referências.
Mas criar e fazer algo
é muito mais importante.
E a gente tem que sentir, todos,
não culpados, mas sentir sim, a gente
nesse momento.
Então a gente traz aqui
também um dado muito forte,
falando um pouco sobre as sevirólogas,
que hoje 40% das casas
são comandadas por mulheres.
Se a gente vai pra outros lugares,
como comunidades,
a gente vê que 70%
é comandado pelas mulheres.
Mas nem as mulheres
são tão representadas assim,
na política e também na mídia.
As mulheres, hoje, estão também, a gente
fala nas sevirólogas, nas fazedoras,
elas estão cada vez mais sendo
as propagadoras de um novo "mindset"
de sociedade, de um novo pensamento.
Cada vez mais a gente vê,
e eu fico muito feliz como mulher,
vendo mulheres fazedoras brasileiras,
também sendo propagadoras,
sendo esse megafone.
Eu vejo que a partir dessa tecnologia,
de ter as redes sociais agora como mídia
e as pessoas terem voz,
a gente vê que alguns movimentos
começam a emergir de vários lugares,
mas é muito interessante ver que essa
mulher fazedora também está fazendo isso,
pra mudar muito a realidade.
E o que que a gente pode aprender
com essa energia feminina?
Eu mesma, quando tive que fazer as minhas
estratégias pra não ficar com meu primo,
e a gente como mulher
está muito acostumada a servir,
a gente foi muito oprimida
e tendo sempre que ser aquela pessoa:
como eu tenho que me portar
para servir alguém;
para ser aceita pelo homem.
Meu pai me dizia sempre assim:
"Ih, não sabe cozinhar, não vai casar".
Ou minha tia dizia: "Amnah, tu está
com 18 anos, ninguém vai te querer".
E aí eu dizia: "Gente,
eu quero fazer faculdade".
"Ah, o marido vai te deixar
fazer faculdade."
E eu dizia: "Meu Deus, como vou
contornar toda essa história?"
Aí descobri lá que meu pai
não gostava de um certo biotipo,
que meu primo tinha esse certo biotipo,
eu falei: "Pai, olha só. Por favor.
Vamos fazer assim, eu escolho
outro namorado, mas esse aí..."
Ele: "Ah, é verdade.
Então vou escolher um filho
de um brasileiro moderno pra você casar".
E aí eu consegui enrolar.
Mas isso tudo pra dizer que esse jeito
da mulher também ser meio...
não é manipuladora, mas vamos dizer
que ela tem uma certa articulação
de entender e muitas vezes por ter sido
reprimida e prestar muita atenção,
ela tem uma sensibilidade talvez
de fazer conexões e redes e de misturar.
Porque também é a mulher
que gera um filho, ela que traz a vida.
Se a gente ver, muitas vezes eu falo,
que se as mães não mudarem o mundo,
quem vai mudar?
Porque nada mais forte
do que a nossa energia feminina.
E uma coisa muito importante
que a gente tem que pensar,
quando pensa em mistura,
e aí, como eu estava
falando antes, de empatia,
é o quanto que a tecnologia,
sim, veio pra nos ajudar a misturar,
mas o quanto muitas vezes
um Facebook da vida não é a realidade,
não é a nossa realidade.
Então o algoritmo do Facebook,
eu não sei se todos estão familiarizados,
ele muitas vezes mostra
pra ti só o que você gosta,
então quanto mais tu dá "like"
nos assuntos, nas pessoas,
ele começa a criar um algoritmo
pra tu só receber aquilo.
Só que isso não é uma realidade,
isso é muito perigoso.
Porque esse momento
que a gente está vivendo no Brasil,
é um momento de polarização,
muitas vezes acontece porque as pessoas
se empoderam de determinados pensamentos
porque acha que todo mundo
está pensando como ela.
E começa a ficar
muito agressiva quanto àquilo.
Só que aquilo está muito refletido,
talvez, num olhar, que ela está olhando
só para o seu umbigo, literalmente,
ou para sua "timeline".
E ela acha que aquilo é realidade.
E aquilo não é realidade.
Então, na verdade,
a mistura não vai acontecer
na frente do Facebook.
Ela não vai acontecer
se a gente não se movimentar.
A mistura tem a ver com movimento.
Então, a primeira questão aqui
de provocação que eu trago é:
a gente enquanto povo brasileiro
precisa sair do armário.
Fazer uma espécie de terapia coletiva.
Porque a mudança, na verdade,
vem de dentro, do autoconhecimento,
de eu não ter vergonha de dizer:
"Ah, os índios que estão lá, sem-terra,
eles não fazem parte da minha vida".
"Ah, porque os negros que estão morrendo
não fazem parte da minha vida."
"Ah, porque os palestinos refugiados
que estão vindo pro Brasil, ou iranianos,
ou as crianças que estão morrendo
não fazem parte da minha vida."
Porque o meu território aqui
está muito bem guardado.
Só que a gente
não é isso, gente, desculpa.
A gente é brasileiro e brasileiro
é um monte de mistura.
E vai ficar cada vez mais misturado.
Não tem essa coisa de ser uma raça.
E é essa nossa grande riqueza abundante!
Só que se a gente não tiver
autoconhecimento e ver que isso é forte,
a gente não vai
se empoderar enquanto povo.
E se a gente não se empoderar,
enquanto povo, enquanto nação,
e muita gente de fora não quer
que a gente se empodere enquanto povo,
porque nosso território
é muito interessante,
a gente vai deixar com que essa
inteligência coletiva se vá.
Se vá pela radicalização, se vá pela briga
e se vá pela polarização.
A gente tem que entender
que tendências estão do nosso lado,
que a coisa mais interessante que acontece
pode ser uma ideia que nem o Afroflix,
que pode ser que nem uma poeta,
porque eu acho, a MC Carol,
ou formas de se vestir de pessoas
que estão trazendo um estilo próprio
de se vestir e não pra fora.
Olha tudo que o Brasil tem, imagina
se a gente só trabalhasse dentro do Brasil
quanto interessante a gente
teria de ideias e de inovação.
Como dizem, na verdade todos os criativos
na área de inovação, independente,
os mais citados por escolas
muito bem renomadas, eles falam:
"Pra uma grande ideia nascer,
ela tem que ter uma equipe heterogênea".
E tem que ter uma mistura
entre essas pessoas.
A gente tem tudo isso.
Então, primeira coisa
que eu estou provocando aqui,
porque esse evento é de ação,
é muito de consciência e ação, é:
cada um aqui deve ser
um agente de mistura.
E se não for, não estou querendo deixar
vocês culpados, não é bem essa "vibe".
Mas na verdade é tipo:
eu, sim, posso ser um agente de mistura.
Eu médico, eu advogado, eu criativa,
eu pesquisadora, eu comunicadora.
Eu sempre quis ser uma grande comunicadora
que existe aí, popular brasileira.
Eu dizia: "Ai, meu sonho
é ser a futura Fulana".
Por quê?
Porque eu queria misturar
o povo todo, botar na televisão
e trazer as coisas que eram do Brasil.
Aí eu descobri:
"Não, eu posso fazer isso".
Então o que comecei a fazer
como um agente de mistura?
Primeiro: reconhecer
diferentes referências,
pra ter uma visão do coletivo, certo?
Mas eu não preciso só reconhecer e andar.
Eu, na verdade,
também preciso espalhar isso.
Eu tenho que ser um inseto.
Eu tenho que ser a zika do bem.
A gente tem que grudar no fulano, pegou,
pegou, pegou, todo mundo pegou.
Tudo misturado. Ai meu Deus, começa
a sentir aquele funk começa a ficar louco.
É isso, entendeu? Essa é a vibe.
Não é: "Ai, isso não faz parte de mim,
eu quero ir para Miami". Não!
Não. Entendeu? Porra!
(Aplausos)
Então a ideia é que vocês
saiam daqui empoderados:
"Eu sou um agente da mistura.
Eu sou um agente da mistura".
E o que é ser um agente da mistura?
É conectar redes.
E principalmente falar com pessoas
que vocês não falariam,
ou conectar pessoas
que não se falariam espontaneamente.
A gente não pode negar e bloquear
aquele cara que a gente acha revoltado.
Ele tem que ouvir o que
estou falando no Facebook.
Ou, eu estou na família.
Família é ótimo pra isso.
Tem aquela mesa da família que está lá:
"Ah, mas essa pessoa aí..."
O aniversário da Morena, minha filha...
Ah, Morena, olha que engraçado...
Minha filha se chama Morena.
Eu sou tão misturada,
ela nasceu loira de olho azul.
Então pra gente entender que a gente
é isso, aceita tudo, tudo misturado.
Então, no aniversário da Morena, eu trouxe
um ônibus de pessoas, foi em Xerém,
e eu trouxe um monte de gente
que eram meus amigos,
da família do meu marido, tinha gente
evangélica, gente não evangélica,
tinha gente branca, gente preta,
aí entrou um monte de gay, amigos meus,
desceram do ônibus: "Uuuh!"
Tudo purpurinado.
E aí eu me lembro a galera assim,
toda em volta da festa,
muita gente, uma festa gigante,
e todo mundo assim.
E teve uma hora que eu estava na piscina,
assim, meio... meio assim, feliz,
(Risos)
e eu olhei pro lado e falei:
"Gente, que bagunça isso aqui,
não preciso ser a apresentadora,
isso aqui é uma grande mistura!"
E foi muito engraçado, teve batalha de rap
mas também teve samba,
e foi isso, foi lindo,
porque pessoas talvez...
um evangélico olhar um gay,
era uma coisa, meu Deus,
ele ficava olhando na piscina assim.
(Risos)
E meu amigo, nada discreto:
"Quer purpurina? Quer purpurina?"
Então essa era um pouco a história.
Num aniversário consegui fazer isso,
a gente pode fazer isso em qualquer lugar.
Então, ser um agente de mistura é:
criar novas narrativas, trazer novas
referências, disseminar histórias reais,
entender que a gente é colorido, diverso,
e que dessa diversidade
nascem coisas e ideias geniais.
E nos respeitar enquanto povo colorido.
A nossa alegria, a nossa purpurina
tem que ser respeitada.
A nossa verdadeira riqueza está nisso.
E não ser revoltados,
não ser brigões, isso não é nosso.
Nós estamos importando isso.
Porque todos nós, na verdade,
somos coloridos e somos puros na mistura.
Gente, obrigada.
(Aplausos) (Vivas)